so let's get started so I'm gonna talk
about how to craft a conversational API
with dialogue flow and Apogee edge we're
gonna have the Google home mini talk to
Apogee edge we're just gonna talk to a
back-end system let me introduce my
co-presenting partner here what should
we talk about on today's webcast we
should talk about how to build a
conversational application and how to
use Apogee to connect it to an existing
enterprise system that sounds great I'm
happy I could help thank you
you are welcome good bye so here's our
agenda first we're gonna talk about how
to build a conversational application
what is a conversational application and
why is it interesting next we'll talk
about how to connect it to the backend
so we have an existing back-end system
and we're gonna talk about how we can
adapt this and build an experience API
that's specific to this device so it
needs a specific set of protocols how
will we make that happen and then after
that we'll follow up with question and
answer so what are conversational
applications and why are they
interesting so think of these as chat
BOTS and smart assistants so an example
of this is something you might see on a
web page where you're interacting with
customer service we're doing some
predefined tasks like that you might see
this over a messaging service also also
think about smart assistants things like
Google assistant Siri Alexa things that
you would interact with applications
that run within those devices are also
conversational applications there's a
great case for these so the case for
conversational applications is pretty
strong 80% of customer interactions can
be resolved with a well-designed chat
bot there's sixty five billion dollars
in potential salary savings from chat
BOTS and sixty percent of consumers want
easier access to self-service solutions
for customer service in 50 percent of
enterprises will be spending more per
annum on BOTS and chat BOTS to create
traditional than they would on
traditional mobile applications so
interesting case for these things
primary use cases for this would be
things like connecting businesses with
their customers so how can you connect a
customer service agent how would you
control IOT devices and how can you
connect businesses to their employees
we're gonna run into some challenges
when we try to build one of these things
a lot of the systems that we've designed
are just not ready for this so let's
look at those the first one is we need
to provide an intuitive user experience
using natural language if you would have
talked to a chat bot just a few years
ago you'd find the conversation to be
very restrictive if you followed the
script exactly you might get good
results but if you wander at all it
would get confused it would get lost and
it would be a very frustrating
experience what we're gonna see today is
this has changed dramatically dialogue
flow which we'll talk about is going to
provide a very good and intuitive
conversational experience for us it'll
be like talking to a person and that's
our goal there should be a natural
experience that doesn't require the user
to adapt how they communicate we're
gonna connect that new experience to an
existing enterprise system and that's a
challenge when we built our original
enterprise systems we weren't thinking
about speaking to them you weren't
thinking about any kind of
conversational interface so we need to
build a whole facade on top of that that
facilitates this and then the third part
is we need to provide a great
application developer experience so we
need an infrastructure in place we need
an API program in place that makes it
easy to create new applications like
this for developers so how do we build
an application what are the parts of
this solution so first thing we're gonna
talk about day is dialogue flow dialogue
flow empowers developers to build
natural and rich conversational
experiences so you can talk with
dialogue flow it will build up a series
of conversations in there keep track of
what you're talking about and what we're
gonna do in here you're gonna have that
send in action over to Apogee edge the
second part in here is we're going to
talk to an existing system to get
information in the case of my
demonstration we've got a gym on the
other side and you can ask the gym when
there are classes you want to sign up
for a particular class things like that
that's a restful service and it's
existing but it doesn't speak the right
protocol so we'll see how to map that
it also requires authentication you need
username and password to get into this
it uses a service account for that so we
need to work around that there's no
traffic management on this existing API
so if we hook up a million of these
things and they start talking we may run
into some scalability problems and
finally there's no caching in place so
we don't have anything to allow this to
perform and to be able to handle the
kind of traffic that we may get from
having new devices so we'll solve those
problems finally we're gonna look at a
pudgy edge and a pudgy edge is what
we're going to use to adapt this to the
new interface so we'll build some
policies with an Apogee edge that
allowed this device to talk to the
backend and allow the backend to respond
in the right protocol for the device so
let's look at a demo and then I'll dive
in behind that and we'll see how we
built the demo so back to the assistant
hey google talk to demo Jim sure here's
the test version of demo Jim hello I'm
the demo Jim application what can you do
you can ask me which classes are
available on a day when a class is
available and you can ask me to sign you
up for a class what classes are
available on Friday yoga indoor cycling
kickboxing are available on Friday when
is yoga offered yoga is available on
Friday at 9 a.m. 11 a.m. 6 p.m.
sign me up for the 11:00 a.m. class
you're signed up for yoga on Friday at
11:00 a.m. thank you you are welcome
goodbye so what's behind that demo how
did I make that happen how did we get it
to talk so let's dive into that and take
a look so the first thing we used in
there was dialogue flow so the challenge
here is how do we build that
conversational front-ends that it can
respond to questions and have answers
and keep track of what people are doing
in there so that's where dialogue flow
comes in so dialogue flow
go over here dialogue flow is where
we're going to build natural and rich
conversational experiences so this is
going to give us a new way to interact
and build products it's going to use
conversational AI on there to make sure
that we're having a good conversation so
what we build in here can be deployed to
a number of different places we can
deploy it to the Google assistant -
Alexa - Facebook messenger on slack
other places like that so that's what
we're gonna build this rich
conversational experience okay so if you
want to learn this take a look at dialog
flow calm there's a blog on there
there's some Doc's on there I worked
through some tutorials to get up to
speed on this so if I wanted to build
something in here I'm gonna click over
here on go-to console from within there
I'm put into this place we're going to
build an application so there's a few
things in here to talk about intense are
things that we're going to say this is
what we plan to do so which classes are
available on Friday I want to know which
classes are available on Friday that's
my intention
there's entities entities are things
that the system knows about a particular
date or the name of a class or something
like that there's a number of built-in
system entities and then there are also
custom ones that you can define
fulfillment is where this would go to be
fulfilled in this case it's going to be
a web hook that calls out to Apogee edge
and then integrations is where we'll
deploy us so that's gonna be the
different devices that can run on I'll
dive into each of these individually and
we'll take a look at that so let's start
with intents so you heard me say which
classes are available
so within intense what we're gonna do is
these are different things that people
would say we'll start with where I
started with this was I give it a name
which class is when is what I chose to
call this particular intent and has an
input context and has an output context
so the input context is something that
would constrain whether it's called or
not a certain condition must be met or
dialogue flow has to be in a particular
state before this is allowed to be
called in this case this is one of the
first things that's going to be asked so
I haven't put any kind of input context
in there that would constrain how this
is called because I want it to be called
immediately
next down here I've got an output state
so after this has been completed the
state of the system is asked which
classes when and this five over here is
the duration that's how long this
context will stay in memory there's also
some parameters associated with this
like the date so when I say next Tuesday
or on Friday it will remember that and
it's going to keep that in context so
that I don't have to keep saying Tuesday
every time I want to talk to the device
next thing to look at in here are these
training phrases so what you do is you
type in a few examples of how somebody
might interact with this so what classes
are offered tomorrow tell me which
classes are offered tomorrow which
classes are available today what classes
are available on on Tuesday or Monday or
things like that which classes are open
on Monday these are all examples of ways
that people would say this now the great
thing here is this does not have to be
an exact match it's helpful if it's
close but doesn't have to be exact
you'll notice that some of these things
are highlighted in yellow those are
entities that dialogue flow has spotted
for me
so this maps to a date this is gonna be
sis date so when I say tomorrow it's
gonna map that to a particular calendar
date for me and it's going to put that
into a parameter so that's what the
yellow is in here
next thing down here is actions and
parameters so when somebody asks this
question I don't have the answer right
here in this particular spot I need to
go call a system and get this
information when they ask what classes
are available I need to go do a query
and look up a list of classes find that
translate into the right format and then
return to this system so what I've got
in here is fine class find which classes
is the name of the action and then
there's some parameters that get sent
over to my web hook with that so I'd
like to send the date and the date
original and the difference between
those two the date is a particular
calendar date and date original is how
they asked so if they said like next
Tuesday or Friday that's the words that
they used for that and then if I can't
get an answer from an external system I
want to have a fallback in here and I'm
going to say sorry I was not able to
find which classes are available on that
particular date so these are the
parameters that's the action these are
some responses that would get called
if you know the answer like if they say
thank you you can say you're welcome
right here with just this if it needs to
call it to an external system we're
gonna come down here under fulfillment
and we're gonna slide this slider it
says enable webhook call for this intent
and that means it's gonna call your
webhook and it's gonna pass these
parameters in this action word in a JSON
body where you can process it so that's
one intent that's in here a few others
that I have in here you can do things
like fly find class times
so let's alright let's look at another
one here let's find classes when so you
can ask when a class is a particular
class and then we can sign up for a
particular class book class now notice
on this one that there's a constraint on
the way in here there's a context that
has to be fulfilled before we get into
here so they have to have asked when the
classes are before they can sign up for
one that's just something I put in here
to demonstrate that so this context has
to be satisfied before this will even be
considered as an answer to something
somebody is asking and there are some
examples register me for spinning on
Tuesday registered me for the yoga class
on Tuesday at 9:00 a.m. so the few
different ways they can talk to this
these checkboxes down here in actions
they mean that these things are required
so if they forget to put those in there
we want to prompt them so if they don't
tell us what the day is for example
we're going to say on which day and
we're going to prompt them for that and
then once we get the answer it will
continue similar to the last one we're
gonna pass a date a time and we're gonna
pass a class name in this case so those
are the intents that I have built into
here next thing to look at our entities
so the yellow ones in here are our
built-in ones the the purple in here or
the pink in here that is a particular
time those are system ones these
brownish ones over here these are these
are different entities that I've defined
so it knows about regular system things
that typically pop up in conversations
but there are some things that it
doesn't know about that you wanted to
find for your application so in my case
I have names of classes like yoga
and spinning and cardio boxing and
things like that I need to tell it about
those things so I've come over to
entities here and I've created a new
entity called a class name and that's
gonna describe that class so within
there I'm gonna list these out these are
different ways somebody might describe a
class kickboxing yoga indoor cycling
those are ways that they might describe
them you can also define synonyms over
here so someone might describe
kickboxing as kickboxing or cardio
boxing indoor cycling might be indoor
cycling spinning or biking those are all
different ways they could do that and if
we check this box up here allow
automated expansion what that's gonna do
is that's going to use the AI in the
speech API is in Google cloud and that's
going to make it so it will recognize
these other things that are also similar
to this that we didn't necessarily list
in here so that's how we enter entities
in here the next thing to look at is
fulfillment in here so how do we get an
answer when somebody asks a question
when they ask what classes are available
on Friday how do we get an answer for
that so we're going to call out to a web
hook here and it's going to respond so
within there we've got a URL this is a
pudgy edge in this case and that is my
API proxy that's going to go and find
answers for me I need to send in an API
key in order to get validated by that
system and to identify what this agent
is so we're going to have an API key in
here and that's going to be passed in
and that's going to identify this system
the other option in here is to write the
code right down here in the inline
editor so you can write cloud functions
for firebase they can be hosted down
there and you can run it straight in
line I'm interested in the apogee edge
application here because I'm integrating
with an existing system and I've got a
great way to map this request into that
and finally we've got integrations in
here so this is where we would deploy
this once it's all written so you get it
all up and running and working then you
deploy it on a projector a particular
device or platform so in my case I'm
running it on the Google assistant
that's the first option here we could
run it inside a web page facebook
Messenger slack a few other options in
there there's a lot of different choices
for where we deploy this and how it
works
so what would I do at this point I've
built these intents I've got some
entities I've set up
fulfillment I've got a few integrations
checked in there how do I test this out
well it turns out there's a nice testing
harness right in here
and one nice thing about this is this
gonna show us the details of what that
body will be that's sent over to the web
hook so let's find out what classes are
available on Friday so I typed that in
there it's gonna make a call out and
it's gonna get a context back an answer
back so what we see here is I asked what
classes are available on Friday and it
answered with yoga indoor cycling
kickboxing are available on Friday and
it also set a context asked which
classes when and it sent this over to
Apogee edge it processed it found an
answer and it returned the way I figured
out what it was going to send was I
click down here on diagnostic info and
there's the JSON body of what's gonna be
sent over there so the interesting parts
of this are we're gonna see within here
query result we're going to see an
action so the action was find which
classes and then the date down here is
an actual calendar date and then this is
how I spoke that date I said on Friday I
didn't say I didn't say 2018 511 and
then we can see the response that comes
back from the system it's going to set a
context and it's going to return a few
more parameters at the bottom there
excuse me
so that's our basic information that
gets sent back and forth I use this to
try and figure out what I should send
over to Apogee edge and how to process
it and things like that so if we
continue our conversation so we've asked
we know which class isn't available
let's find out when yoga is offered
now it remembers that the first time I
asked about Friday so I didn't have to
say Friday again I just said when is
yoga offered and it says yoga is
available on Friday at 9:00 a.m. 11:00
a.m. and 6:00 p.m. it's important in
these applications to keep that context
so somebody doesn't have to keep asking
the same thing over and over again when
we have a conversation with another
person this implied context is in the
conversation so if I say hey what's the
billable on Friday the next time I ask
it's just assumed that I'm still talking
about Friday so that date is stored in
the output context from the first call
and it's sent into the parameters of the
second call and again we can look down
here at diagnostic info and we can get
an idea of what's going to be sent over
to our web hook for fulfillment so here
we are down here the action this time is
fine class times the specific class name
is yoga and here's the two different
ways we specified the date the calendar
date and then how I spoke that the first
time and we see the answer that comes
back from the backend system in there so
that's our information that's how we're
gonna work with dialogue flow looks good
here you know looks like this is doing
exactly what I want the next step would
be figure out how to map that to a
back-end system and we'll dive into how
that works so at this point you would
deployed on an integration what I did
was I set it up on Google assistant I
can run it on my phone I can run it on
the Google home and it's gonna work in
either case so the web hook request and
response flow the way to look at that I
went and looked at the reference
documentation on this to figure out how
to do this so go over to dialogue flow
calm look at the documentation click
over to reference scroll down to web
hook request in response so here's the
request for the web hook it tells you
what that format is you've got to pass
in a session and response ID query
result I'm sorry that's the yeah and the
request and then there's some details
under here of what the object is and you
can click through on that it'll give you
all the details on that particular thing
on the response side we're gonna see
that this text comes back so we can have
a text that's spoken and we can also
have text
shown on the screen so for some of these
integrations like we're using slack or
if we're using the assistant on a phone
for example we can return a series of
cards with possible answers on there we
can return images URLs things like that
or we can just have fulfillment text if
we're speaking to a device for example
so that's our request in response and
that's the reference on how that works
so the next tool to look at is the
existing service so we've got an
existing service in there and we want to
call that existing service and we want
to have it give us answers back so let's
explore what that looks like so here's
our existing service what I've got here
on the screen is just a tool that I use
to to call restful services and get
answers back so in this case I've got a
URL up here and my response comes back
over here so if I call my back-end
system and it's going to talk to the
classs API we're gonna pass in a
particular date and with that date we'll
look at what classes are available so we
pass in this date and we get back an
answer that looks like this now notice
that's regular JSON that's just an array
in there that's coming back with three
different values that's not suitable to
be read so there's that specific webhook
response we have to do and we map that
over at Apogee so I have two things to
do I have to take the webhook request
that came in I've got to remap that into
a restful call that looks like this with
a date on there and then I've got to
take this response that comes back and
I've got to remap that into something
that's appropriate for the device so it
can read it can have those contexts and
things like that
so similar that that gives us a list of
classes this is how we request the times
for a specific class so at the end of
this URL we have slash classes slash
yoga it's going to return the times when
yoga is available if I want to register
for a class I'm gonna do a post
operation two classes yoga students I'll
pass in my information and then I'll get
back a confirmation number so those are
the three different calls that we make
to the backend system so let's look at
how to map that so the next thing to
look at is Apogee edge and and how we
handle these webhook requests and
responses that are coming
and coming out so I'm gonna go into
Apogee edge this is where I'm gonna
build my API proxy to handle this and
what I'm building today I would describe
it as an experience API a lot of times
if you were gonna support a new mobile
application and you've got an existing
enterprise system you would build an
application API just for that so this is
an API just to support that mobile
application and maybe it takes all that
data and it's gonna shrink down that
payload a little bit and make it
something that's appropriate for a
mobile device think of this in the same
way but instead of mobile this is going
to be a voice application so we're going
to take that that existing response and
map it down to something in here so
let's look at what that looks like I'm
gonna click on API proxies over here and
we'll open up the proxy that I built
just for this so we've got booking agent
in here now if you noticed on my last
application the URLs changed there's
gonna be something different on the URL
depending on what type of thing I'm
doing there's slash classes slash
classes yoga slash classes yoga students
things like that so I have a need to
change that URL so what I've done down
here is I've defined a back end target
and within there I've got a little curly
brace thing here that says action suffix
that's a variable that I'm gonna set in
here I'm gonna pull that out of the web
hook request that's coming in and I'm
going to map that to the right URL for
the back end the way I've done that is
to put that on the end of the URL here
as a variable that will be satisfied in
here let's click over to develop and see
what's in there
so within Apogee edge this is where we
would build our API proxy this is where
me to do my mapping so a few things are
called on the request we'll see the
response come back that's what's
depicted over here I've got a number of
policies in here that are going to
manage this request in response flow for
me and then down here I've got some
actions I have a pre flow which is this
stuff up here this gets called every
time no matter what's on the end of the
URL so these are things that I always
want to do the next three are
conditional things so I've defined one
of these for every action that's sent in
so if somebody asks what classes are
available on Friday
well we'd find which class
that would be that one and I have one of
these for every action and then there's
a post flow down here that gets called
unconditionally I don't have anything in
there so for every time somebody invokes
this no matter what they put on the end
or no matter what they say to it this
will get invoked and then one of these
will be invoked conditionally based on
what's matched in there so let's dig
into that in just a little bit more
detail so the first thing we want to do
when this is called is I want to verify
an API key when I set up my web hook in
there I put in an API key it's passed as
a header that will identify which
application is calling in and which
one's talking to me I want to keep track
of that so I can collect analytics on it
and I also want to make sure it's an
authorized agent I might have different
traffic management policies in here
based on what that application is and
what it's doing so by processing that
API key I get a little bit of security
in there but I also get a lot of rich
metadata in there about who the caller
is I've put a spike arrest policy in
here so if I deploy this application it
gets really popular maybe somebody runs
a Superbowl ad or something I don't want
a million of these things talking to my
back-end and crashing everything so this
spike arrest is there just to shut that
down if too many of these call in too
quickly I'm gonna remove some headers so
dialogue flow will send me a very
specific request it's got a bunch of
headers in there that are needed in here
but the back end doesn't need those
doesn't understand them it's just not
appropriate to send them so what this
code in here will do is we're going to
set the content type to application JSON
which is what my back-end expects and
then we're going to remove a few
different headers in there that we just
don't need so it'll take those out of
the request and reform the request the
next one is get action so this is going
to grab that action from the the web
hook request that's sent in so the RHIB
web hook request within the body of that
there's an action and there's a session
ID and those are two pieces of
information that I need we'll save the
action so this is the analytics this is
a statistics collector and Appaji edge
what this is going to do is keep track
of what the actions are so I want to
have a report at some point and I want
to have different stats
who's calling what and how popular these
different things are this next policy in
here is a key value lookup so this is
going to be where we're going to get the
username and password for the back-end
system the backend system in this case
requires a service account it's got a
username and password
we'll pull that out of an encrypted key
value map and then this policy will set
the password so we can get authenticated
with the back-end system so that's gonna
happen with every call let's look at the
first one in here where we sign we say
find which classes so in this case
they've specified a date which classes
are available on Friday we're gonna grab
the date out of there and we're gonna
get the original date so date is the
calendar date and then date original is
the spoken date the reason I want to
grab this is when I put together the
response I want to tell them which
classes are available on Friday and not
5:15 2018 I want to speak back to them
the same way that they asked a question
so that's the request side of this down
on the response side I'm gonna get that
response back from let's look over here
for what that one looks like I'm gonna
get a response back that looks like this
so an array of classes in there and I
need to translate that into an
appropriate webhook response for
dialogue flow so that's what's gonna
happen down here in this JavaScript
policy so class is two string so what
this does is this is just gonna iterate
over that array and turn it into a
string that looks more like a spoken
sentence and we'll set a variable in
there called class string so if there's
no classes set it to that otherwise just
make it a comma-separated sentence and
then return that and then finally we're
gonna set the response in here so this
is the kind of response that we have to
send back to dialogue flow and within
here we're gonna have fulfillment text
that's what it's going to speak and
these curly braces in here that's the
evaluation of a variable so yoga
kickboxing etc are available on Thursday
that's what that's going to say when it
goes back and then we need to set that
output context we need to put dialogue
flow into a particular state so that's
what this does the way we do that is we
send back the session ID
text and then this text right here is
whatever that context should be and a
timeout for that it's gonna last for
five minutes if somebody stops talking
to the device for five minutes it'll
reset itself and then we're gonna have a
bunch of parameters that we're gonna
pass back the date the original date the
list of classes things like that so
that's this particular flow we go to the
next one we're going to look at what
happens as that follow-up so they may
ask they know which classes are
available on Friday but now they want to
know when is a specific class available
so when is yoga available so we're gonna
grab out of here the we're gonna parse
that action we'll get that in the pre
flow and then we're also gonna grab the
class name out of here when it's yoga
available and then the second one here
is going to grab the date and in the
original date and we'll store those as
variables then we're gonna change the
request around I didn't talk about this
too much on the first one but I'm always
getting a post in here an HDTV post and
my back-end system is restful it expects
it get in there so I'm gonna change the
verb to it get I'm going to rebuild the
URL by setting a value for this action
suffix so that was on the end of my
target URL I'm gonna put that in there
and that's gonna call the back end and
then on this one I'm gonna get back a
list of times so I've got JavaScript in
here to map that array of times into a
sentence so it's gonna come back like
this and then we've got to create a
string that looks like that and that's
what this code is doing in here we're
building up a time string and then
that's going to be returned down here so
down here we'll see that it gets
returned as a string so that's going to
be put into there yoga is available
Tuesday at 3 p.m.
that's what that will look like when
it's completely filled out and sent back
to the agent and then we're gonna set a
context again this time the context is
asked find class times and then it's
going to last for five minutes and we're
going to send back which class they were
talking about so we can remember that a
date and a date original now third step
in here they want to register for a
class so what does that look like when
they go to register for a class first
thing is
we need to know which class so that's
gonna come across in the context it'll
be in the parameters under that action
section so we're going to grab the class
name out of that body we're going to get
the date and we're going to get the time
and then we're gonna change the request
around again in this case it is a post
so we're gonna leave that alone but
we've got to set the payload to
something different we're going to pass
in the information about the user in
there and that's going to be used to
register for the class at a particular
time and then on the response side we're
gonna get a confirmation number the
backend system will return a
confirmation number for that
registration we want to return that and
then we're gonna build up the response
in here like we did in the other flows
so down here you're signed up for yoga
Friday at 3:00 p.m. or whatever they
asked for and we're gonna set a context
in here of class booked and then we're
going to return that confirmation number
in there so that's our three conditional
flows in here the way that I set this up
so that these would be called is within
the pre flow here the key part here is
this get action so this is gonna be
agent action and it's gonna grab that
out of that JSON body when it comes in
and then if we look at down here in the
code these three gray things over here
these three conditions these have a
conditional expression on them so if the
agent action is register for class then
there's this flow in here and if the
agent action is fine class times that's
in here so that's how I set those up so
let's look at this in a little bit more
detail let's see what's going on in here
let's click on the trace utility over
here and let's start up a trace session
and look at what this might look like
when somebody calls it so I'm going to
talk into my phone to set up this agent
and we'll look at what it's actually
sending across talk to demo gem what
classes are available on Thursday
yoga indoor cycling kickboxing are
available on Thursday when is kickboxing
available kickboxing is available on
Thursday at 9 a.m. 11 a.m. 6 p.m.
sign me up for the 11 a.m. class you're
signed up for kickboxing on Thursday at
11 a.m. okay so there's our flow that's
gonna happen in there and we'll see
these different things come into a pudgy
edge this helps us debug it figure out
what was set in the requestor response I
had this a little bit off when I first
did it and it wasn't responding the
right way I looked in the trace utility
in here and I looked at it and I
realized that I'd had a few things set
wrong so we see these come in there's
our evaluation of the API key the spiked
arrest so on so forth here's our request
coming in there's the actual body that
it's cents and that and and that sort of
thing we can look at the different
stages in here we can see what's called
in there what matched it which action
was followed and here's the interesting
part
we'll see that this was sent in as a
post v1 booking agent and then when it
goes out completely different URL and
now it's a get and a completely
different URL in there
so we've dynamically built up that URL
we've completely changed the request
around and we're going to send that to
the back end and then when the response
comes back we'll see that we get a array
in here of these class names that's
coming back flow through the JavaScript
we'll see that the response gets built
up and then we got a completely
different response in there that's
coming back on this side that's
formatted in a very different way so pop
through the different things in here and
get an idea of what's flowing back and
forth between here and how that's gonna
map into your enterprise system so
that's a look at our demo today
next thing to look at if this was
interesting to you might be thinking how
do I get started with this how can I
start to build these sort of things so
what I did to get started on this I
hadn't used dialogue flow before I'd
heard about it I thought it was pretty
cool I thought I'd go check it out so I
went out and
read the documentation and I worked
through the tutorial so there's a
tutorial out there where you build a
pretty simple application that got me
90% of the way there I worked through
that and then I referenced the docs a
little bit but I'd say about two days to
learn this and it was pretty easy to do
next thing to do definitely visit Apogee
comm so on Apogee you're gonna find all
the information about Apogee edge you're
trying to talk to an existing system I
think it's the best way to map that and
make that happen
tons of information out there references
and documentation on how to do that you
can sign up for a free trial that sort
of thing
community Apogee comm is a great
resource for learning more about Apogee
there's tutorials on there and then
there's a bunch of people who can help
you out when you're stuck if you want to
learn more about Apogee sign up for a
free trial there is on the apogee
webpage just see a big red button that
lets you sign up for a free trial
account unlimited access it'll spin up a
cloud account for you
Apogee also offers hands-on enablement
so if you want to learn more about how I
did what I did an Apogee edge could sign
up for an API Jam this is a class that
we have it's a hands-on lab so you can
work through some tutorials with our
experts and they'll help you out there's
more of these product demo webinars we
do these all the time great way to learn
about different things and interesting
topics on Apogee so at this point we're
gonna pause for some questions we'll be
back in just a few minutes
you
okay so it looks like we got a few
questions let me go through these and I
will answer them so what happens if
someone asks something that the agent
can't answer so great question this
happens all the time what do you do when
somebody goes outside the boundaries of
your application so you can put some
fallbacks in there I don't know how to
answer that or that's not something I
know how to do you can also have some
hooks in there like I'd like to talk to
a I'd like to talk to a human I'd like
to talk to a representative things like
that and that can change the flow that
could call the web hook and take
whatever action you need to that could
send it on to somebody else it could
send them over to a webpage wherever you
want to do how do I get up to speed on
this so I built some applications that's
the best way to do it get hands-on with
it you can read about it but you don't
really experience it until you're in
there so go into dialogue flow look at
that diagnostic information that's going
to show what the body is flowing back
and forth and things like that that was
very helpful for me I made a few
mistakes in here I didn't really
understand how contexts worked in here
so for context specifically there's a
really nice blog entry out on the dialog
flow blog page that will give you some
details on how context works after I
read that I understood how it worked
can you change the device voice so can
we change the voice of this thing and
how it speaks to us yes you can so
there's a few different voices that are
available and you can switch between
those it's nice thing to do for
usability because then you know that
you're talking to one application or
another application next question can
this be integrated with slack so yes you
can integrate it with slack so you've
got a few more capabilities in there
what you saw today was strictly a voice
based demo in here where I'm speaking
back and forth when you're in slack you
can return more custom context in there
you can return URLs you can return
pictures things like that so look under
the integration sections and dialogue
flow and there's some details in there
also in the documentation it talks about
features that are specific to some of
those platforms so you can return custom
things for that you can have multiple
responses in your web hook response and
they can be custom like you have one for
the assistant and one for slack and you
can return different things
next question is can you integrate
Google Calendar with Apogee edge so yes
Google Calendar has a great API and
Apogee is your tool for working with
api's so look at the documentation for
Google Calendar you'll find that there's
some very nice API is in there you can
build a facade in Apogee edged Apogee
edge can handle that log in for you and
and things like that so that's all the
questions we have today and with that
I'm going to say thank you very much for
attending the webinar